tell me everyone everyone the Donaire hi
we're gonna start with the general
storyteller certainly I can't see a
thing but I can hear your voice my
background is as a film editor that's
how I started doing all kinds of whether
it was documentaries commercials
features TV series dramas and the like
but I had the great good fortune back in
1966 to have met Graham Ferguson totally
by chance in New York I got talking to
Graham and it turned out he had just
started a film project for Expo 67 and
it was an experimental film with 11
projectors 35-millimeter that all had to
be synchronized you didn't see the 11
screens at once you saw saw them on it
the the audience moved past the screens
and it was out of the expo experimental
film multi-image craze that imax arose
that's when the invention happened right
after that theaters van were mostly
almost flat audience seats and you
looked up at a postage stamp on the wall
and imax changed all that because of
certain designs that had gone into Expo
67 and put the audience much closer to
the screen and in this in this raked
position so that every seat was really
good you weren't looking over somebody's
shoulder and on the reason you could do
that was because of the bright clear
very steady picture the experiential
side of of IMAX is absolutely perfectly
tailored to and also the ending the
addition of 3d to a subject subject
matter that I like to direct which is
mainly underwater in space airless
environments if you will I don't seem to
work anyplace where that you can
actually breathe so I don't really
direct them the thing that's that's the
short answer
it's the the wonderful astronauts and
cosmonauts that that that are there that
actually do that on the day what we do
is we train james Niehaus my director of
photography and i train them we give
them about 30 hours of training over
several months equipping them with
everything they need to know to be to
make a feature film in other words we
tell them about lighting about framing
about moving the camera about 3d how to
record sound how to direct each other in
scenes we send them up with a shopping
list of scenes but we also encourage
them to vary from that and and and
create their own things as well as
what's on our list and the classic thing
I always say to them is you know if an
alien comes up and pasted his face on
the window don't not shoot it because
it's not on my list you know you're the
directors up there you you know you're
you go for it we probably could have got
a camera up there to just live on this
station but you couldn't get film
back-and-forth to it in a timely fashion
and film gets radiated on orbit quite
severely if you leave it for more than a
couple of months it can even on the
first day depending on the altitude
you're at and what solar activity is
going on so right then and there the
edict was you got to go digital for the
effects on me of digital it it was a
very much old dog new trick and that's
where Technicolor came in because
Technicolor you know they saved my bacon
because they became the official archive
source and the keeper of the high-res
data when it came to throwing out EDL's
and doing a complex timeline Technicolor
did all of that and beautifully we have
to provide everything from DCPS to film
to specially-made dome theater
presentations to de 3d it's sort of all
things and without Technicolor's
guidance and the coordination that they
you know that we that we
did with Technicolor and IMAX together
technically we would have had a lot of
stumbling blocks and they made it go
extremely smoothly